lives lost Shattered by Monday's
earthquakes Northwest Syria's
humanitarian crisis made worse the
region was hit just as hard as cities
across Southern turkey
but here the people devastated by over a
decade of War wait for help already
Millions live in tents the Quake has
made tens of thousands more homeless
but it's cold 90 days of our family are
living in this tent we lost our homes we
need everything clothes food the
children are always hungry we have
nothing to keep warm
rescue teams have been working non-stop
with little resources and alone as hopes
of finding survivors fade they say they
have been abandoned by the International
Community to face the worst disaster
they have encountered requests for heavy
machinery never came on Thursday the UN
acknowledged search and rescue
operations covered five percent of the
devastated sites
we lost 27 members of our family in The
Quirk seven bodies have still not been
retrieved the civil defense needs help
the cross-border aid operation from
Turkey resumed on Thursday after it was
disrupted partly to damage the
infrastructure on both sides of the
Border but the U.N was criticized for
providing what many said were
insignificant supplies it says more
assistance is coming Aid agencies
however say politics is getting in the
way of using more direct and effective
routes our report lays out
several concrete ways that that could
happen opening additional cross border
routes from Turkey opening up cross-line
channels from other parts of Syria
including the Northeast towards the
Iraqi border or the South obviously
there would need to be a lot of
guarantees of non-interference that the
government would need to accept in order
for that channel to work and then an air
Bridge government areas too are in a
dire situation U.N agencies which
operate there are promising to scale up
response across the country
but to cross front lines they need
approval from Damascus which has been
accused of using access as a political
pressure and to use more border
crossings will require a U.N resolution
because of the objection of the Syrian
government and its Russian Ally so what
we need is the capacity to scale up the
existing type of response that existed
prior the earthquake
um
I mean the question of crossline or
cross-border is a I would almost say the
mood point in many ways because what we
need is a modality that works medical
support is needed to an already
crumbling infrastructure the crisis
deepens in this war-torn land zanohuder
al-shazira